如何构建智能体团队
本文是一份面向实践的操作指南
旨在系统性的讲解如何
从零开始构建一个由多个AI
智能体协作组成的智能体团队
内容涵盖从需求判断架构设计角色
划分技术实现到部署运营的完整流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文延续此前AI智能体开发
多智能体协作架构两篇
姊妹篇文章所建立的理论框架
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
聚焦于将这些理论原理转化
为具体可执行的实践步骤
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
文中涉及的具体技术方案与工程建议
均为基于公开技术实践与
一般工程逻辑的分析性讨论
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
读者在实际项目中应结合自身
具体技术栈与业务需求进行调整
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第一章引言
从理论到实践
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
1.1本文与此前两篇姊妹篇文章的关系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
在此前的AI智能体开发与
多智能体协作架构两篇文章中
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
本系列已经系统介绍了
智能体系统的核心工作原理
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
感知规划行动循环
工具调用记忆系统等
以及多智能体协作的
五种核心架构模式
层级式对等协作式
流水线式辩论共识式黑板系统
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
这些内容为理解智能体团队是什么
为什么这样设计提供了理论基础
但对于真正希望动手构建
一个智能体团队的读者而言
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
仍然缺少一份将这些理论原理转化
为具体可执行操作步骤的实践指南
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这正是本文希望填补的空白
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
1.2像组建团队一样思考的核心比喻
本文将贯穿始终的采用一个核心比喻
将构建智能体团队的过程
类比为一名管理者组建并
运营一个人类工作团队的过程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一比喻并非仅仅是修辞手法
而是具有实质性的方法论指导价值
正如组建一个高效的人类团队
需要明确团队目标
合理设计岗位职责
招募匹配人才
建立协作流程
制定质量把关机制
并进行持续的团队管理与优化
构建一个智能体团队
同样需要经历高度类似的一系列步骤
这一比喻框架也将成为本文后续章节
展开具体操作指南的核心组织逻辑
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
1.3本文的适用读者与使用方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
本文适合已经对大语言模型API调用
基础的软件工程实践具备一定了解
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
希望系统性的学习如何从零开始规划
构建并运营一个多智能体协作系统的
开发者技术负责人或产品经理阅读
本文的15个核心步骤第二章至
第十六章按照实际项目推进
的大致时间顺序组织展开
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
读者可以将其作为一份可以按图索骥
逐步推进的实践检查清单Checklist
而后续的两个实战案例章节
则通过具体场景的完整推演
帮助读者更为直观的理解如何将前述
15个步骤串联应用到实际项目之中
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第二章第一步
判断你是否真的需要一个智能体团队
2.1 这是最容易被忽视
但最应当认真对待的第一步
在正式动手设计构建智能体团队之前
第一步也是最容易被
开发者忽视跳过的关键步骤
是审慎判断当前所面对的具体任务
是否真的需要采用多
智能体团队协作架构
还是采用一个设计精良
的单一智能体即可胜任
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
这一判断步骤之所以至关重要
是因为如本系列此前
文章所反复强调的
多智能体架构相较单一智能体架构
通常意味着更高的开发实现
复杂度更高的模型调用成本
开销以及更复杂的调试维护难度
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
2.2判断清单
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
哪些信号表明你需要一个团队
而非一个人
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
参照本系列多智能体协作架构一文
第2章所讨论的单智能体能力边界
以下信号通常表明当前任务更
适合采用智能体团队协作架构
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
信号一任务天然涉及多个性质迥异
需要不同专业视角的子环节
例如任务同时涉及富有创造性的内容
构思生成与严谨审慎的事实
准确性核查这两种性质截然不同
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
甚至存在一定内在
张力的思维模式要求
此时将其拆分给分别
专精不同职责的智能体
分别承担
通常优于要求单一智能体在同一次
连续推理过程中反复切换角色心态
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
信号二任务的信息处理量或
上下文长度显著超出单一
智能体合理的上下文承载能力
例如任务需要综合处理
来自多个不同信息来源
篇幅庞大的原始资料
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
此时将信息收集处理工作
拆分给多个并行工作的智能体
分别承担
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
通常能够获得更优的处理效果与效率
信号三
任务本身具有相对清晰
的多阶段处理流程结构
且各阶段需要不同的工具能力配置
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
例如
任务天然包含信息检索数据分析内容
撰写质量审查这类具有清晰顺序结构
且各环节所需工具能力
存在显著差异的处理流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
信号四任务对最终产出结果的
准确性可靠性存在较高要求
需要引入独立的交叉验证机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
例如任务产出结果将被用于对外
正式发布或指导重要决策
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
此时引入独立的审查校验角色智能体
能够显著降低最终产出
出现错误疏漏的风险
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
2.3反向判断清单
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这些情况下
单一智能体可能是更优选择
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
与此同时
以下情况通常意味着单一智能体
架构可能是更为务实高效的选择
任务本身相对简单
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
能够被清晰的在有限
的几个步骤内完成
任务对响应时效性要求较高
难以承受多智能体协作
架构所带来的额外延迟开销
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
团队自身技术能力储备与
项目时间预算相对有限
难以承担多智能体架构更高的
开发实现与调试维护复杂度
以及任务的容错空间相对充裕
即便产出结果存在一定误差瑕疵
也不会带来严重的现实后果
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
2.4建议的决策流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议读者在正式启动
智能体团队构建工作之前
先尝试采用一个设计相对
精良的单一智能体方案
进行初步的任务处理效果验证
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若发现该单一智能体方案确实在
处理效果处理效率或质量可靠性
方面遇到了难以通过进一步优化
提示词或工具配置来解决的瓶颈问题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
且这些瓶颈问题与本章第2节
所列举的信号特征相吻合
此时再考虑升级
采用多智能体团队协作架构
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
这一先验证单智能体
再按需升级的渐进式决策路径
通常能够帮助开发者避免
过早引入不必要的架构复杂度
第三章第二步选择
团队的整体架构模式
3.1回顾五种核心架构模式
在确定确实需要构建
一个智能体团队之后
下一步是从本系列多智能体协作架构
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
一文所系统介绍的5种核心架构模式
层级式对等协作式
流水线式辩论共识式黑板系统中
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
选择最适合当前具体
任务特点的架构模式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
或是若干种模式
相结合的混合架构方案
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
3.2架构模式选择的决策框架
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
为帮助读者更为便捷的
完成这一架构模式选择决策
本文提供以下简化的决策框架
读者可以依次自问以下问题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
问题一任务是否存在天然的
线性处理顺序结构
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
若是流水线式架构通常是首选
问题二任务是否需要一个
具备全局视野的角色
来统筹协调多个相对
独立的子任务模块
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若是层级式架构通常是首选
这也是当前实践中应用最为广泛
上手门槛相对最低的架构模式问题三
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
任务是否需要通过多元视角的碰撞
讨论来获得更为周全可靠的判断结论
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若是对等协作式或辩论
共识式架构值得考虑
具体选择哪一种
可以参考任务对判断结论
准确可靠性的要求高低
若要求极高
倾向于选择结构更为
严谨的辩论共识式架构
若相对宽松
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
采用结构更为灵活的对等协作式即可
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
问题四任务的具体处理路径
与所需专业能力组合
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
事先难以完全预判确定
需要根据问题求解过程
中动态浮现的具体需求
灵活引入相应能力
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若是黑板系统架构值得考虑
但需要注意
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一架构模式的工程
实现复杂度相对较高
建议仅在确实存在这一现实需求
且团队具备相应技术
能力储备的情况下选用
3.3混合架构的实践建议
在实际项目实践中
纯粹采用单一架构
模式的情况相对较少
更为常见的做法是根据
具体任务不同环节的特点
灵活组合采用多种
架构模式的混合方案
例如整体采用层级式架构
进行任务的总体统筹协调
但在其中某个具体需要
多元视角审视的子环节
如内容质量审查环节
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
内部又采用辩论共识式的协作机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议读者初次
尝试构建智能体团队时
优先从相对简单上手门槛
较低的层级式架构入手
积累实践经验
再根据具体项目需求
逐步尝试更为复杂的混合架构方案
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
3.4架构选择的书面记录
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议读者在完成架构模式选择后
将选择的具体架构方案及其选择
理由以简明的书面形式记录下来
例如绘制一份简要的架构示意图
标注各个智能体角色
及其相互协作关系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
这一书面记录不仅有助于后续
开发实现阶段的团队内部沟通协调
也为项目后期进行架构方案调整
优化时提供了重要的参考基线依据
第四章第三步角色
设计与职责划分方法论
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
4.1借鉴人类团队岗位设计的思路
如本文引言所提出的核心比喻
设计智能体团队中各个
具体角色的职责划分
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
可以充分借鉴人类组织中
岗位设计的成熟方法论思路
即首先明确完成整体任务目标
所需要涵盖的核心职能模块
再针对每个核心职能
模块设计相应的具体岗位
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
及智能体角色
并为每个岗位明确
界定清晰的职责范围
所需具备的专业能力及工具
调用权限与知识背景设定
以及与其他岗位之间的协作接口关系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
4.2职责划分的具体操作步骤
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
步骤一任务分解
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
首先将整体任务目标分解为
若干个具有一定独立性边界
相对清晰的子任务模块
这一分解过程可以参考本
系列AI智能体开发一文第8章
所讨论的任务分解技术思路
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
步骤二职能归类
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
将分解得到的各个子任务模块
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
按照所需要的核心
能力类型进行归类整合
判断哪些子任务模块可以
合并交由同一个角色统一负责
哪些子任务模块因所需能力差异较大
应当分别设立独立的专门角色负责
步骤三角色命名与职责说明撰写
为每个最终确定的角色赋予
一个清晰易于理解的角色名称
如信息检索专员内容
撰写专员质量审查专员
并撰写简明扼要的职责说明
明确该角色的核心职责
范围与预期产出成果形式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
步骤四协作接口设计
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
明确梳理各个角色之间的协作关系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
哪个角色的产出将作为
哪个角色的输入起点
哪些角色之间需要建立
双向的沟通反馈机制
4.3职责划分的合理粒度把握
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
在实际操作中
一个常见的困惑是应当
将角色职责划分的多细
设立多少个具体角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议遵循以下原则
职责划分的粒度应当以每个角色所
承担的具体职责能够被清晰准确的
用一段简明的文字描述为基准
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若某个角色的职责说明
需要涵盖过多性质迥异的
具体工作内容才能完整描述
这通常意味着应当考虑将其进一步
拆分为多个更为聚焦的具体角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
反之若拆分得到的多个角色
其职责说明高度相似
边界模糊不清
则应当考虑将其合并
为一个统一的角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
作为一个实践经验参考
绝大多数实际应用
场景中的智能体团队
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
其涉及的具体角色数量通常
在3-8个左右的区间范围内
能够较好的平衡专业化分工
的效果收益与整体系统协调
管理复杂度之间的权衡取舍
4.4角色职责说明文档的标准模板
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
为保证角色设计工作的规范性与
后续开发实现阶段的顺畅衔接
本文建议为每个设计确定的角色
形成一份标准化的角色职责说明文档
其核心内容通常应当包括
角色名称核心职责概述
具体的输入信息来源
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
预期的输出产出成果格式
需要调用的工具清单
与其他角色的协作关系说明
以及该角色在履行职责过程中应当
遵循的关键行为准则或注意事项
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这份文档将在本文第8章中作为撰写
具体系统提示词的重要输入依据
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
第5章第4步
选择技术栈与开发框架
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
5.1技术栈选择的核心考量维度
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
在完成整体架构模式与
角色职责划分设计后
下一步需要确定具体的技术实现路径
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文此前姊妹篇文章第15章已经概览
介绍了主流的多智能体开发框架类型
本章将进一步提供具体
的技术栈选型决策指导
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
核心考量维度通常包括团队
自身既有的技术能力储备与偏好
项目所选定的架构模式与
不同框架各自的适配契合程度
对系统调试可视化能力
社区生态成熟度的实际需求
以及项目对开发实现速度与后续
定制化灵活性之间的权衡取舍偏好
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站！欢迎访问我们网站！欢迎访问我们网站！"
The text is clearly written in Chinese and is centered within the image.
5.2三种典型的技术实现路径选择
路径一采用成熟的通用型或
专用型多智能体开发框架
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一路径的优势在于能够充分利用
框架已经封装好的通用基础设施组件
如记忆管理工具调用
编排多智能体通信协调等
显著缩短开发实现周期
尤其适合团队技术能力储备相对有限
或项目时间预算较为紧张的情况
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
其局限在于采用线程框架通常
意味着需要在一定程度上遵循该
框架预设的架构范式与设计约束
对于具有高度定制化需求的复杂
项目场景可能存在一定的灵活性局限
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
路径二基于大语言模型服务
提供商的原生API能力
进行轻量化自主实现
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一路径的优势在于能够最大程度的
保留架构设计的灵活性与定制化空间
避免引入不必要的框架抽象层复杂度
尤其适合架构需求相对明确
且团队具备扎实工程
实现能力的项目场景
其局限在于
需要团队自主承担
更多底层基础设施组件
如状态管理错误处理多智能体
通信协调逻辑的设计与实现工作
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
相应的增加了开发实现的
时间投入与工程复杂度
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
路径三混合路径
即在核心业务逻辑层面采用自主实现
同时借助成熟的第三方组件库
处理相对通用标准化
程度较高的具体技术环节
如向量数据库检索
能力日志追踪监控能力
这一路径在实践中较为常见
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
能够在保留核心架构
设计灵活性的同时
避免在通用技术环节进行
不必要的重复造轮子工作
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
5.3技术栈选型的实践建议
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
本文建议
对于初次尝试构建智能体团队
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
且团队技术能力储备相对有限的读者
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
优先考虑采用路径一
选择一个与自身选定
架构模式适配度较高
社区生态相对成熟活跃的现成框架
快速构建原型验证方案的实际可行性
待项目发展到需要更高
定制化灵活性的成熟阶段
再考虑是否需要向
路径2或路径3迁移调整
第六章第五步设计通信与
协作流程6.1从抽象角色关系
到具体通信流程的细化
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
在本文第四章完成各角色的职责
划分与协作接口的初步梳理后
本步骤需要将这一相对抽象的
协作关系描述进一步细化为具体
可实现的通信协作流程设计
这一设计工作需要参照本系列
多智能体协作架构一文第9章所
讨论的通信协议设计原则
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
明确具体的通信内容格式通信时机
触发条件以及信息流转的具体路径
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
6.2绘制协作流程图
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文强烈建议读者在正式
进入编码实现阶段之前
先绘制一份清晰的协作流程图
直观呈现各个角色之间信息
流转的具体路径与先后顺序关系
可以参照本系列多智能体协作
架构一文第4章至第8章中各
架构模式对应的示意图形式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一流程图的绘制过程本身
也是一次对整体协作设计
合理性进行审慎审视的重要契机
通过将抽象的协作关系可视化呈现
开发者往往能够更容易的发现
设计中可能存在的逻辑漏洞
如某个角色的必要输入信息来源缺失
或是流程中存在无法有效
闭合收敛的循环依赖关系
6.3明确每个通信节点的具体内容规范
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
针对流程图中的每一个具体通信节点
本文建议进一步明确以下细节
该通信节点传递的具体信息
内容应当包含哪些核心要素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
采用何种具体的结构化格式
如JSON格式的具体字段
定义来组织这些信息内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
以及该通信节点的触发时机与条件
是在前置环节完成后立即触发
还是需要满足某个特定
的判断条件后才触发
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
6.4预留必要的动态调整空间
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在设计具体的通信协作流程时
本文建议在严格遵循预先
设计的固定流程结构的同时
也应当适当预留必要的动态调整空间
以应对实际执行过程中可能
出现的事先未能完全预判的情况
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
例如设计相应的机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
允许某个环节的智能体角色
在判断当前获取的输入信息
不足以支撑其完成既定职责任务时
能够主动触发向前置环节
请求补充信息的反馈通信
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而非机械的按照预先设定的
固定单向流程继续执行下去
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第七章第六步构建共享记忆
与上下文系统7.1记忆系统设计
在团队构建中的实践定位
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
如本系列AI智能体开发一文第7章
所详细讨论的记忆系统原理
在实际的智能体团队构建工作中
记忆系统的设计需要落实为具体
的技术组件选型与工程实现工作
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本章将聚焦于团队协作场景下
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
记忆系统设计的具体实践要点
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
7.2团队协作场景下
需要管理的几类信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在智能体团队协作场景中
通常需要设计相应机制
来管理以下几类信息
任务及共享上下文
即整个团队所有角色都需要
了解的关于当前整体任务
目标与关键约束条件的信息
这类信息通常应当在任务启动之初
便统一提供给所有参与协作的角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
角色间流转的中间产出信息
即各角色在完成自身
职责任务过程中产生
且需要传递给后续协作
环节的具体产出内容
这类信息的管理与本文第6章讨论
的通信协作流程设计密切相关
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
团队层面的长期记忆积累
如适用即随着团队持续运营
积累的历史执行经验信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这类信息的管理通常需要借助向量
数据库等检索增强技术手段实现
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
7.3具体的技术实现选型建议
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
对于任务集共享上下文与
角色间流转的中间产出信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在技术实现上
通常可以采用相对简单直接的方案
例如构建一个统一的任务状态对象
可以是一个结构化的数据结构
随着任务执行进程的推进
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
各角色在完成自身职责任务后
将相应的产出结果写入这一
共享状态对象的相应字段
后续环节的角色则从这一共享状态
对象中读取其所需要的相关信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
对于 团队层面的长期记忆积累
则通常需要引入向量
数据库等专门的技术组件
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
实现基于语义相似度的
历史经验信息检索能力
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
7.4上下文信息传递的精简化设计
如本系列多智能体协作
架构一文第11章所强调
本文再次提醒读者
在具体设计每个角色实际
接收到的上下文信息内容时
应当遵循按需提供的精简化设计原则
仅向每个角色传递其
真正需要的相关信息
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
而非不加区分的将全部历史
累积信息一并传递给每一个角色
这一设计原则的贯彻落实
对于控制整体系统的
模型调用成本开销
以及保证各角色推理决策的聚焦效率
具有重要的实践意义
第八章第七步
工具集成与权限配置
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
8.1 为每个角色配置工作所需的装备
延续本文的核心团队比喻
为智能体团队中的每个角色
配置相应的工具调用能力
类似于为人类团队中的每个
岗位配备完成其具体工作所
必需的设备资源与系统访问权限
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本步骤的核心工作是依据本文
第四章中每个角色职责说明文档
中所明确的需要调用的工具清单
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
逐一完成具体的工具集成实现工作
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
8.2工具集成的具体实现步骤
步骤一工具清单梳理确认
逐一核实每个角色所
需要调用的具体工具
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
如网络搜索代码执行特定
业务系统的API接口调用等
确认这些工具是否已经
具备可用的技术实现方案
无论是调用现成的第三方API服务
还是需要团队自主开发
实现相应的工具接口
步骤二工具接口的标准化封装
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
参照本系列AI智能体开发一文
第6章所讨论的工具定义设计原则
为每个具体工具编写清晰
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
准确的功能描述与输入参数格式规范
确保大语言模型能够准确理解每个
工具的具体功能与正确的调用方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
步骤三权限范围的精确配置
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
严格遵循本系列文章反复强调
的权限最小化安全设计原则
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
为每个角色仅配置其履行既定职责
所必需的最小工具调用权限范围
避免赋予任何角色超出其
实际职责需求的过度宽泛权限
例如若某个角色仅需要具备
信息查询检索的能力
则不应当为其额外配置具备数据修改
删除等更高风险操作能力的工具权限
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
步骤四工具调用的错误处理机制实现
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
参照本系列AI智能体开发一文第6章
所讨论的错误处理机制设计原则
为每个工具的实际调用
过程实现相应的异常捕获
与结构化错误信息反馈机制
确保当工具调用出现异常时
相关的角色智能体能够
获得清晰的错误反馈信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
并据此判断后续应当采取的应对措施
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
8.3高风险工具的特别审慎处理
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
对于涉及数据修改资金交易对外
发布等高风险性质的工具能力
本文建议在完成本章所述的
常规工具集成配置工作基础上
进一步结合本文第十二章将要
讨论的人在环路监督机制设计
确保此类高风险工具的实际调用执行
始终处于必要的人工
审核确认监督之下
而非完全交由智能体自主决策执行
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第九章第八步
编写系统提示词
每个角色的岗位说明书
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
9.1系统提示词是角色
行为的核心决定因素
如本系列AI智能体
开发一文第5章所讨论
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
系统提示词的设计质量对智能体最终
的实际行为表现具有极为重要的影响
在智能体团队的构建工作中
为每个角色精心撰写
高质量的系统提示词
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
相当于为团队中的
每个岗位撰写一份详尽
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
清晰的岗位说明书
这份说明书的撰写质量将直接决定该
角色在实际协作执行过程中能否稳定
准确的履行其被赋予的职责定位
9.2系统提示词的标准结构框架
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议每个角色的系统提示词
遵循以下标准结构框架进行撰写
具体内容基于本文第4章所形成
的角色职责说明文档转化而来
角色定位声明
清晰说明该角色在整个团队协作体系
中的具体身份定位与核心职责使命
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
输入信息说明
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
说明该角色将会接收到
哪些具体形式的输入信息
以及应当如何理解解读这些输入信息
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
核心任务指令
清晰具体的说明该角色
需要完成的具体任务要求
包括预期产出成果应当
满足的质量标准与格式规范
可用工具说明
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
列出该角色被授权
使用的具体工具清单
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
并说明每个工具的适用
场景与正确使用方式
这部分内容通常会结合大
语言模型服务提供商所支持
的原生工具调用能力机制
在技术实现层面进行
相应的结构化封装
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而不仅仅依赖纯文本描述
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
行为准则与边界约束
明确说明该角色在履行职责过程中
应当遵循的关键行为准则
以及明确禁止或需要
审慎对待的行为边界
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
例如明确说明该角色不
应当擅自跨越职责边界
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
代为完成本应由其他
角色负责的工作内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
输出格式规范
明确规定该角色最终产出结果
应当遵循的具体结构化格式规范
以便于后续协作环节能够准确
解析利用该角色的产出内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
9.3少样本示例的补充设计
参照本系列AI智能体开发一文
第5章所讨论的少样本示例技术
本文建议针对每个角色
尤其是职责相对复杂
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
容易引发行为模糊的角色
在系统提示词中补充
一到两个具体的示例
展示在典型任务情境下
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
该角色应当如何进行推理分析
并产出符合预期要求的具体结果
这一补充设计通常能够显著提升该
角色行为表现的稳定性与一致性
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
9.4系统提示词的迭代优化实践
本文提醒读者
系统提示词的撰写
通常难以一次性达到理想的完善状态
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而是需要在后续本文第11章所
讨论的测试与迭代优化环节中
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
基于实际测试运行
观察到的具体行为表现
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
持续进行针对性的调整完善
读者应当以迭代优化的心态看待
系统提示词撰写这一工作环节
而非期望在初次撰写时便能够
穷尽考虑所有可能出现的边界情况
第十章第九步
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
设计冲突解决与质量把关机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
10.1 为团队设立必要的质量管理体系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
延续团队协作的核心比喻
正如一个健康运转的人类团队
通常需要建立相应的质量
把关审核机制与冲突处理流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
来保证团队最终产出成果的质量水准
并妥善处理团队协作过程中
不可避免会出现的观点分歧
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
智能体团队同样需要在架构
设计中明确纳入相应的质量
把关与冲突解决机制设计
而非仅仅依赖各个角色各自独立
完成任务后简单拼接汇总最终结果
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
10.2质量把关机制的具体设计方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
参照本系列多智能体协作架构一文
第13章所讨论的冲突解决机制设计
思路
本文建议在智能体团队的架构设计中
明确设置以下质量把关设计要素
设立专门的审查角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
即在团队角色设计中
明确设立一个或多个专门
承担质量审查职责的角色
如前文实战案例中
提及的质量审阅专员
负责对其他角色的产出
成果进行独立的质量核验
明确审查环节的具体判断标准
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
为审查角色的系统提示词中
明确列出具体的质量判断标准清单
如事实准确性逻辑完整性
格式规范性等具体维度
确保审查工作具备相对
客观可操作的判断依据
而非仅凭模糊笼统的
整体印象进行判断
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
设计不合格产出的返工处理流程
明确规定当审查环节发现某个角色的
产出结果未能达到质量要求标准时
系统应当采取的具体后续处理流程
如将任务退回至原产出角色
要求重新修正
或是触发人工介入处理
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
10.3冲突解决机制的具体设计方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
针对本文第四章角色设计过程中
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
可能存在职责边界交叉
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
进而容易引发观点
分歧冲突的角色关系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议在架构设计中预先
明确相应的冲突解决处理机制
具体可以参考本系列
多智能体协作架构
译文第13章所介绍的优先级
层级裁定机制独立仲裁角色
机制或协商式迭代收敛机制
并根据具体项目对决策质量
与决策效率的实际权衡考量
选择恰当的具体机制设计方案
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
10.4将质量把关与冲突解决
机制融入整体协作流程
本文提醒读者
质量把关与冲突解决机制不应当
被视为在整体协作流程设计完成
之后另行附加补充的独立环节
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而应当在本文第五章设计
具体通信协作流程的过程中
便一并纳入统筹考量设计
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
作为整体协作流程结构中
不可分割的有机组成部分
第十一章
第十步构建最小可行团队MVP
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
11.1 避免一步到位的常见误区
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
在完成前述从需求判断到质量把关
机制设计的一系列前期规划工作后
许多开发者容易陷入的一个常见误区
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
是试图在首次开发实现阶段便完整
构建出涵盖所有前期设计考量功能
齐全完善的最终版本智能体团队系统
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
这种一步到位的开发思路往往
会显著延长首次获得实际可用
系统与真实反馈的时间周期
也增加了在开发过程中难以及时
发现并纠正早期设计缺陷的风险
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
11.2最小可行团队的构建原则
本文强烈建议读者遵循软件工程
领域广泛认可的最小可行产品
MVP理念
优先构建一个仅包含核心必要角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
覆盖核心主干协作流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
暂时省略部分次要功能环节
如复杂的长期记忆系统
精细化的错误处理与重试
机制的简化版本智能体团队
以尽可能快速的时间周期
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
获得一个能够端到端跑通核心
任务流程的初步可运行系统
11.3最小可行团队应当具备的核心要素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
一个合格的最小可行团队版本
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
通常应当具备以下核心要素
涵盖完成核心任务目标所必须的
数量精简的关键角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
通常可以先从本文第四章
设计确定的全部角色中
筛选出其中最为核心
必要的少数几个角色
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
实现最基本的角色间
信息流转通信机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
即便这一机制在实现细节上相对简化
尚未完全落实本文第5章
所设计的全部流程细节
以及能够端到端的处理至少一个具体
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
明确的典型任务场景
产出相应的最终结果
即便这一最终结果的质量水准
尚未达到最终期望的完善标准
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
11.4从MVP到完整版本的渐进式扩展路径
在获得最小可行团队版本
并通过本文第11章将要
讨论的测试迭代环节
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
验证其核心协作机制的基本可行性后
读者可以采取渐进式扩展的开发路径
逐步补充完善此前简化
省略的次要功能环节
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
如逐步引入更多前期
设计中规划的次要角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
完善更为精细化的记忆
管理与错误处理机制
并在每一次功能扩展迭代后
持续进行相应的测试验证工作
以确保整体系统的稳定性与可靠性
能够随着功能复杂度的逐步提升
得到同步的验证保障
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第12章第11步
测试与迭代优化
12.1 构建针对性的测试用例集合
参照本系列多智能体协作架构
一文第16章所讨论的评估方法论
本文建议读者在获得
最小可行团队版本后
着手构建一套针对性的测试用例集合
这一测试用例集合应当
尽可能覆盖以下几类典型场景
核心主干流程下的常规典型任务案例
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
涉及边界模糊
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
容易引发角色间职责
判断分歧的挑战性案例
以及故意引入异常干扰因素
如模拟工具调用失败
提供不完整或存在矛盾冲突的
输入信息的异常压力测试案例
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
12.2建立系统性的观察记录习惯
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在实际执行测试用例的过程中
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议读者建立起
系统性的观察记录习惯
详细记录每一次测试执行过程中
各个角色具体的推理决策
过程实际产出结果以及整体
协作流程的实际执行路径
而不仅仅关注最终的整体
产出结果是否符合预期
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这种细粒度的执行过程观察记录
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
对于精准定位识别具体是哪个环节
哪个角色的表现存在问题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
具有至关重要的实践价值
也是本系列多智能体协作架构
一文第16章所强调的分环节评估
方法论在实际操作层面的具体落实
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
12.3常见问题的诊断与对应的优化方向
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在测试迭代过程中
读者可能会遇到以下几类常见问题
本文针对每类问题提供相应
的诊断思路与优化方向参考
某个角色的产出结果
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
反复未能符合预期要求
通常应当首先审视该角色
对应的系统提示词设计
是否存在职责描述模糊不清
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
缺乏必要的具体事例引导等问题
并进行针对性的补充完善
角色之间的信息传递出现丢失或误解
通常应当审视本文第5章所涉及的
通信协作流程与信息格式规范是否
存在设计不够清晰明确的问题
整体协作流程出现难以有效收敛
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
陷入循环往复的情况
通常需要审视本文第9章所设计
的冲突解决与质量把关机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
是否存在缺乏明确终止
收敛条件的设计缺陷
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
12.4迭代优化的持续性认知
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文提醒读者
测试与迭代优化并非在正式部署
上线前需要完成的一次性工作环节
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而应当被视为智能体团队整个
生命周期中需要持续贯彻的常态化
实践活动
即便系统已经正式
投入实际生产环境运行
也应当持续保持对系统
实际运行表现的观察监控
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
并基于观察到的实际问题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
持续进行相应的迭代优化完善工作
这一持续迭代优化的实践理念
将在本文第16章持续运营的
讨论中得到进一步展开
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第十三章第十二步引入人在环路的
监督机制13.1明确哪些环节需要人工
介入
参照本系列AI智能体开发一文
第16章所讨论的安全可控性设计原则
本文建议读者在完成前述核心
功能开发与初步测试迭代工作后
进一步系统性的审视
整个智能体团队协作流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
明确判断哪些具体的
决策节点或操作环节
应当纳入必要的人工
审核确认监督机制
而非完全交由智能体
团队自主决策执行完成
13.2判断是否需要人工
介入的具体考量因素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
具体判断某个环节是否需要
引入人工介入监督机制时
本文建议综合考量以下因素
该环节所涉及的操作
是否具有不可逆性质
如涉及实际的资金交易对外正式
发布内容修改关键业务数据等
The image contains text in Chinese and English. The Chinese text is:
"The Chinese text is:
"The English text is:
The English text is:
该环节的产出结果
若存在错误疏漏
可能造成的实际影响与损失程度
以及当前系统在该环节的实际表现
可靠性水平
基于本文第11章测试迭代
过程中积累的实际观察数据
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
13.3人工介入监督机制的具体实现方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在具体工程实现层面
人工介入监督机制通常
可以采用以下几种具体方式
关键节点的强制暂停确认
即在流程执行到预先
设定的关键节点时
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
系统主动暂停自动化执行流程
将当前的阶段性产出结果
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
连同相关的决策依据说明
提交给人工审核者进行
明确的批准确认或修改调整
仅在获得人工确认后
才继续后续的自动化执行流程
基于置信度的动态触发机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
即结合系统自身对当前决策
结果置信程度的评估判断
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若技术上可行
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
仅在系统自我评估置信度
低于预设阈值的情况下
才触发人工介入审核
而对于置信度较高的常规情况
则允许系统继续自主执行
这一机制设计相较于
强制性的固定节点暂停确认
能够更为精细化的平衡系统自主效率
与必要的人工监督保障之间的关系
事后抽样审查机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
即对于风险相对可控
但依然存在一定质量
保障需求的应用场景
可以考虑采用事后抽样审查的方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而非要求每一次执行都
进行事前的强制人工确认
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一方式尤其适用于需要处理
较大规模较高并发量任务请求
难以对每一次执行都进行
事前人工介入的应用场景
13.4人工介入接口的用户体验设计
本文提醒读者
为人工审核者设计清晰高效的
介入审核操作界面与信息呈现方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
同样是这一环节工作中
值得重视的实践要点
审核界面应当清晰呈现
当前待审核的具体内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
相关的决策依据与背景信息
以及便捷的批准拒绝
或修改调整操作入口
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
避免因审核界面设计不当而导致
人工审核环节本身成为整体系统
运行效率的新增瓶颈制约因素
第十四章
第十三步
成本估算与预算规划
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
14.1成本估算的必要性与实践意义
在正式将智能体团队系统投入
实际生产环境部署运行之前
本文建议读者进行审慎的
成本估算与预算规划工作
这一工作对于确保项目能够在
可持续的成本预算范围内长期
稳定运营具有重要的现实意义
也呼应了本系列多智能体协作
架构译文第17章所讨论的成本与
延迟工程权衡这一核心议题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
14.2成本估算的具体构成要素
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
智能体团队系统的实际运营成本
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
通常主要由以下几方面构成
大语言模型API调用成本
这通常是智能体团队系统运营
成本中占比最大的核心构成部分
其具体金额取决于所
采用的具体模型定价标准
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
每次任务执行所涉及
的实际模型调用次数
对应团队中各个角色的推理决策次数
以及每次调用所涉及的
输入输出TOKEN数量规模
外部工具调用成本如试用
即若团队中的某些角色需要
调用付费的第三方API服务
如专业数据查询服务
图像生成服务等
这部分费用也需要
纳入整体成本估算范围
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
基础设施运营成本
包括支撑系统运行所需要的
服务器计算资源数据库存储
资源等相关基础设施费用
14.3成本估算的具体操作方法
本文建议读者基于本文
第11章测试迭代过程中
针对典型任务案例的
实际执行记录数据
统计计算平均每次完整任务
执行过程中所涉及的模型调用
总次数与输入输出TOKEN消耗总量
结合所采用具体模型的实际定价标准
估算得出平均每次任务
执行的大致成本开销
并结合项目预期的
实际任务处理量级需求
进一步估算得出整体
项目的预期运营成本规模
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
为后续的预算规划
决策提供量化依据支持
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
14.4成本优化的具体实践方向
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
参照本系列多智能体协作架构一文
第17章所讨论的成本优化工程手段
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议读者在完成初步成本估算后
进一步审视是否存在
合理的成本优化空间
具体可以考量的优化方向包括
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
针对团队中不同角色的
具体任务复杂度要求
采用能力与成本相匹配
的差异化模型选型策略
审视是否存在可以通过更为精简
高效的提示词设计与上下文管理
策略来降低不必要的TOKEN消耗冗余
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
以及审视是否存在可以通过
合理的并行处理调度设计来在
不显著增加整体成本的前提下
缩短任务处理的实际时间周期
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第十五章
第十四步
部署上线与监控体系搭建
15.1从开发测试环境向生产环境的过渡
参照本系列AI智能体开发
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
译文第17章所讨论的
智能体部署与工程化议题
本文建议读者在完成前述开发
测试与成本预算规划工作后
进行相应的生产环境部署准备工作
这一过渡过程
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
通常需要完成包括生产
环境基础设施资源配置
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
访问权限与身份认证机制搭建
以及相应的安全防护配置
等一系列工程化准备工作
15.2监控体系的核心构成要素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
一个完善的智能体
团队生产环境监控体系
通常应当涵盖以下核心要素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
任务执行成功率监控
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
持续追踪统计系统实际
处理任务的成功完成比例
及时发现可能出现的
整体系统表现异常状况
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
关键性能指标监控
包括任务平均处理时长
各角色平均调用次数与
响应延迟等性能相关指标
成本消耗监控
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
持续追踪实际的模型调用成本开销
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
及时发现可能出现的
异常成本消耗情况
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
如某个环节出现了
意料之外的过度重复调用问题
异常与错误告警机制
针对系统运行过程中
出现的各类异常情况
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
如工具调用失败率异常升高
某个角色产出结果
质量出现明显下降等
设置相应的自动化告警通知机制
以便技术团队能够及时
发现并响应处理相关问题
15.3日志记录与执行
过程追踪能力的重要性
本文特别强调
为智能体团队系统构建完善的
日志记录与执行过程追踪能力
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
对于生产环境的稳定运营
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
具有极为重要的实践价值
正如本文第12章测试迭代阶段所
强调的细粒度过程观察记录习惯
在实际生产环境运行过程中
同样需要保留能够回溯查看
每一次具体任务执行的完整过程记录
包括各角色的具体推理决策
过程与工具调用记录的能力
以便在生产环境中出现具体问题时
技术团队能够快速准确的
定位排查问题根源所在
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
15.4灰度发布与渐进式上线策略
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
本文建议
对于首次将智能体团队系统
投入实际生产环境的项目
采用相对审慎的灰度
发布与渐进式上线策略
即先在相对有限的
实际业务流量范围内
例如仅处理一小部分实际任务请求
或仅面向内部测试用户开放
进行初步的生产环境实际运行验证
在充分确认系统的实际表现符合预期
且各项监控指标均
处于健康稳定状态后
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在逐步扩大系统承接
实际业务流量的范围规模
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这一渐进式上线策略有助于在
充分控制潜在风险的前提下
稳妥的完成系统向全面
生产环境运营的过渡
第十六章第十五步
持续运营与团队的人事管理
16.1智能体团队的人事管理比喻延伸
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
延续本文引言部分
提出的核心团队比喻
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
智能体团队在正式
投入生产环境运营之后
同样需要进行类似人类团队运营
管理中人事管理性质的持续性工作
包括对各个角色实际
表现的持续评估审视
根据实际业务需求变化
对团队角色构成进行
相应的增员或调整
以及针对表现不尽如人意的具体角色
进行相应的培训优化及
针对性的系统提示词与配置调整
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
16.2持续性能表现评估的常态化实践
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
本文建议
在系统正式投入生产环境运营后
持续保持对各个角色实际表现
质量的常态化评估审视工作
可以通过定期抽样审查实际
生产环境中的具体执行案例
结合本文第15章所
构建的监控体系数据
以及适当引入用户实际
反馈信息等多种渠道
持续评估判断团队中各个具体
角色的实际表现质量是否依然
维持在预期的可接受水平范围内
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
16.3根据业务需求变化
进行团队结构调整
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供优质的服务。欢迎使用我们的网站，并了解更多关于我们网站的信息。"
随着实际业务需求场景的演变发展
智能体团队的角色构成与协作流程
设计也可能需要相应的进行调整优化
例如若发现业务实践中
某类此前未曾预料到的
新兴任务需求场景日益增多
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
且现有团队角色构成
难以有效覆盖处理
可能需要考虑引入新的专门化角色
又或是若发现某个此前设计的角色
其实际承担的职责工作量相对有限
性价比不高
也可以考虑将其职责合并
整合到其他相关角色之中
以简化整体团队结构的复杂度
16.4建立版本管理与变更记录机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
参照本系列AI智能体开发一文
第17章所讨论的版本管理实践建议
本文提醒读者
在智能体团队的持续运营优化过程中
应当建立完善的版本
管理与变更记录机制
对每一次针对系统提示词工具配置
协作流程等核心组件所进行的调整
变更进行清晰的版本记录与
相应的效果对比评估
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
以便在发现某次调整变更
实际带来了负面影响时
能够及时准确的回滚
恢复到此前的稳定版本状态
这一版本管理实践对于保障智能体
团队系统能够在持续迭代优化过程中
维持整体运营的稳定性与可靠性
具有重要的实践价值
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
第十七章
实战案例一
从零构建内容生产智能体团队
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
17.1场景背景与需求描述
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
假设某企业希望构建一个能够
自动化生产营销博客文章的智能体
团队
具体需求是输入一个营销主题关键词
系统能够自动完成资料信息收集
文章初稿撰写事实准确性核查
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
以及语言风格润色优化的完整流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
最终产出一篇符合企业品牌调性要求
事实准确
语言流畅的营销博客文章
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
17.2第一步
需求判断
对应本文第二章
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
该任务涉及信息检索创意撰写事实
核查风格润色这四个性质迥异的子
环节符合本文第二章所述
信号一的判断标准
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
因此判断确实适合采用
智能体团队协作架构
而非依赖单一智能体
17.3第二步
架构模式选择
对应本文第三章
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
由于该任务具有清晰
的线性处理流程结构
信息收集初稿撰写事实核查风格润色
因此选择流水线式
架构作为整体架构模式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
17.4第三步
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
角色设计
对应本文第四章
设计确定以下四个核心角色
信息检索专员
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
负责根据给定主题关键词
检索收集相关的背景资料信息
内容撰写专员
负责基于检索到的背景资料信息
撰写符合企业品牌
调性要求的文章初稿
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
事实核查专员
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
负责对文章初稿中涉及的具体
事实性陈述进行准确性核验
标注可能存在问题的表述
风格润色专员
负责对经过事实核查修正后的
文章内容进行语言风格的优化润色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
确保最终产出内容语言流畅
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
符合企业品牌调性要求
17.5第四步至第九步的关键实施要点
技术栈选择
由于该任务的架构相对简单明确
选择基于大语言模型
服务商原生工具调用能力
进行轻量化自主实现的技术路径
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
通信流程设计
设计相对简单直接的线性流转流程
前一环节的完整产出内容
作为后一环节的直接输入起点
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
工具集成
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
信息检索专员配置
网络搜索工具调用权限
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
其余三个角色主要依赖大语言
模型自身的文本处理生成能力
无需额外的专门工具集成
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
系统提示词撰写
针对每个角色
依据本文第9章的标准结构框架
分别撰写相应的系统提示词
尤其针对事实核查专员
需要在系统提示词中明确列出具体
的事实核查判断标准与流程要求
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
质量把关机制将事实核查
专员的核查结果设计为一个
是否存在问题的判断分支
若核查发现存在事实性问题
则将任务退回至内容撰写专员环节
要求重新修正
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
形成一个有条件的循环反馈机制
而非严格单向的线性流程
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
17.6测试迭代中发现的
典型问题与优化调整
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
在初步测试迭代过程中
可能会发现的典型问题包括
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
信息检索专员检索到的
背景资料信息量过大
信息噪声较多
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
导致后续内容撰写专员
难以有效聚焦提炼核心信息
对此可以考虑在
信息检索专员的职责设计中
增加对检索结果进行
初步筛选提炼的要求
风格润色专员在优化润色过程中
可能无意中改变了此前事实核查
专员已经修正确认的具体事实性表述
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads: "中国是世界上最大的经济体之一。
对此
需要在风格润色专员的系统提示词中
明确强调应当仅调整语言表达风格
而不得改变任何具体
的事实性陈述内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
17.7该案例的实践启示
该案例较为完整的展示了如何将本文
第二章至第十二章所述的核心步骤
具体应用到一个相对典型
结构清晰的内容生产类应用场景之中
尤其值得关注的是
即便是相对简单的流水线式架构
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在实际测试迭代过程中
往往依然会浮现出诸多需要
针对性调整优化的细节问题
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
这也再次印证了本文第12章所
强调的测试迭代应当被视为
一项持续性实践活动的核心理念
第18章实战案例二
从零构建客户服务智能体团队
18.1场景背景与需求描述
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
假设某电商企业希望构建一个
能够处理复杂客户咨询诉求
涉及订单查询退款申请投诉
处理等多类业务环节交织的
复合型诉求的智能体团队
需要在准确理解客户诉求的基础上
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
协调调用多个具体业务处理能力
并最终生成一份综合性的回复内容
18.2第一步至第三步的关键设计要点
需求判断
该任务涉及意图理解多类型业务
处理综合回复生成等多个专业化环节
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
且不同业务处理环节需要调用
不同的企业内部系统接口能力
符合本文第2章所述信号
一与信号3的判断标准
因此确定采用智能体团队协作架构
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
架构模式选择
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
由于该任务需要一个具备全局
视野的角色来统筹判断客户
复合型诉求中包含的具体子问题
并协调分派给相应的专门化处理角色
因此选择层级式架构
作为整体架构模式
角色设计
设计确定以下角色构成
意图理解与诉求梳理专员
承担编排者角色
负责准确理解客户诉求内容
判断其中包含的具体子问题类型
并进行相应的任务分派协调
订单查询处理专员
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
负责所以涉及订单状态
查询相关的具体业务诉求
退款处理专员
负责所以涉及退款申请
相关的具体业务诉求
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
投诉处理专员
负责所以涉及客户投诉
相关的具体业务诉求
综合回复生成专员
负责将各专门化处理角色的
处理结果整合为一份逻辑清晰
语言得体的综合性回复内容
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
18.3第四步至第九步的关键实施要点
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
工具集成与权限配置
订单查询处理专员配置企业
订单管理系统的只读查询权限
退款处理专员配置退款申请
提交相关的接口调用权限
鉴于退款操作涉及实际资金处理
属于本文第十三章所
讨论的高风险操作范畴
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
需要结合相应的人工审核确认机制
投诉处理专员配置投诉工单
创建相关的接口调用权限
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
冲突解决机制设计需要特别考量
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
当客户诉求中同时
涉及多个具体业务类型
如同时涉及订单查询与退款申请时
意图理解与诉求梳理专员
应当如何合理拆分并行分派
给相应的专门化处理角色
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
以及在获得多个专门化
角色各自的处理结果后
综合回复生成专员应当如何合理
组织整合这些可能存在一定信息
重叠或需要逻辑衔接的多方处理结果
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
18.4人在环路机制的关键应用
对应本文第十三章
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
鉴于退款处理这一
环节涉及实际资金操作
具有不可逆性质的特点
本文建议在退款处理专员完成
初步的退款申请资格审核判断后
针对超过一定金额阈值的退款申请
设置强制性的人工审核确认环节
仅在获得人工确认后
才实际执行退款操作的提交处理
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
而对于金额相对较小
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
风险可控的退款申请
则可以考虑允许系统在
满足预设条件的情况下
自主完成处理
这一差异化的人工介入触发机制设计
体现了本文第13章所讨论的
基于置信度或风险程度的
动态触发机制这一实践思路
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
18.5该案例的实践启示
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
该案例相较前一个内容生产案例
涉及更为复杂的层级式协作架构
更多样化的业务处理角色分工
以及更为关键的高风险
操作人工审核确认机制设计
较为完整的展示了本文
所述完整方法论体系
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
在处理相对复杂
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
涉及实际业务系统集成与风险管控
需求的实际应用场景中的具体应用
方式第十九章
常见失败模式与避坑指南
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
19.1失败模式一
角色职责设计过于模糊笼统
如本文第四章所强调
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
角色职责设计的清晰度是保证
智能体团队协作有效性的重要基础
若角色职责说明设计的过于模糊笼统
往往会导致该角色在实际执行过程中
产出结果的质量与一致性表现不佳
避坑建议是
严格严格遵循本文第四章
所述的职责划分方法论
确保每个角色的职责说明能够被
清晰具体的用简明文字准确描述
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
19.2失败模式二
忽视测试迭代环节
过早投入生产环境部署
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
如本文第12章所强调
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
充分的测试与迭代优化
工作是保证智能体团队
系统实际表现质量的重要前提
若开发团队因项目时间压力等原因
跳过或压缩了必要的测试迭代环节
过早的将系统投入实际生产环境部署
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
往往会在生产环境中暴露出大量
此前未能充分发现解决的问题
避坑建议是
即便面临一定的项目时间压力
也应当为测试迭代环节预留
相对充分合理的时间投入
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
19.3失败模式三
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
权限配置过于宽泛
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
缺乏必要的人工监督机制
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
如本文第八章第十三章所强调
严格遵循权限最小化原则
并针对高风险操作环节设置
必要的人工审核确认监督机制
是保障智能体团队系统
安全可控运行的重要基础
若开发团队为追求系统
运行的自动化便利性
而忽视了这些必要的安全防护设计
可能面临系统因推理错误或
异常状况而执行不当操作
造成实际业务损失的现实风险
避坑建议是
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
始终将安全可控性设计
作为智能体团队架构设计
中不可妥协的核心考量因素
19.4失败模式四
缺乏成本意识
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
导致实际运营成本远超预期
如本文第14章所强调
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
若开发团队在项目规划阶段未能
进行充分审慎的成本估算工作
可能面临系统正式
投入生产环境运营后
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
实际产生的模型调用成本显著
超出项目预算承受能力的现实风险
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
避坑建议是
在项目规划的早期阶段便应当
进行相对审慎的成本估算工作
并在后续开发实现过程中持续
关注成本控制这一现实约束因素
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
19.5失败模式5
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
架构复杂度与实际业务需求不匹配
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
如本文第2章所强调
并非所有应用场景都真正需要
复杂的多智能体团队协作架构
若开发团队在实际业务
需求相对简单的情况下
盲目引入不必要的架构复杂度
往往会导致项目开发
实现周期显著延长
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
系统维护调试难度显著增加
而实际获得的效果提升却难以与
所付出的额外复杂度成本相匹配
避坑建议是始终以本文
第2章所述的判断框架
作为决定是否采用多智能体
团队架构的理性决策依据
避免为了追求技术复杂度本身而
偏离了真正的业务价值创造目标
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
第20章结语
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎光临
欢迎光临"
The text is written in a simple, clear font.
像组建团队一样构建智能体系统
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
综上所述
本文以向组建并管理一个人类
工作团队这一核心比喻为贯穿主线
系统梳理了从需求判断架构选择角色
设计技术实现到测试迭代安全监督
成本规划部署运营的完整15步实践
流程
并通过两个具体的实战案例
展示了这一方法论体系在实际
应用场景中的具体落地应用方式
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
需要再次强调的是
构建一个真正稳定可靠
能够创造实际业务
价值的智能体团队系统
The image contains a single line of Chinese text. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
绝非一蹴而就的一次性工程实现工作
而更应当被视为一项需要持续投入
不断迭代优化
完善的长期性实践工作
正如管理运营一个
真正高效的人类团队
同样需要持续的投入
关注与耐心的迭代改进
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。欢迎访问我们网站，我们为您提供更多信息。"
希望本文所提供的这套
系统性实践方法论框架
能够为读者在实际动手构建
自身的智能体团队系统时
提供切实有价值的
操作指导与实践参考
The image contains a single line of text in Chinese. It reads:
"欢迎来到我们网站，我们为您提供各种服务。欢迎访问我们的网站，我们为您提供各种服务。"
帮助读者在这一充满技术挑战
也充满创新可能性的前沿实践
领域中构建出真正能够创造
实际业务价值的智能体协作系统
全文完